[00:00:23] The United States is slowly shutting
down thanks to Corona virus.
[00:00:26][3.8]
[00:00:27] We're seeing more and more states
do what the federal government has been way
too slow to recommend as we continue to be
led by the blind and the incompetent.
Day after day after day, the dishonest, blind
and incompetent Trump administration.
I should add, and this is simply going to
be the new reality for a while.
And I know that it's horrible, that it's horrible
what's going on.
But if we don't start doing these things,
it's going to get much worse.
The stock market and the economy will likely
suffer far more than what we've already seen.
Stocks down 12 percent intraday as we are
filming right now, where my prediction is
we could be down 40 percent from the peaks
of a few weeks ago by the time this is all
said and done, although who can ever predict
the bottom?
But once again, although I hope it doesn't
happen, we have to be responsible.
Whatever the consequences, we have to do what
your state says.
If we want a shot at turning this around and
part of the reason why we now we're increasingly
going to more extreme measures is because
the initial reaction was so incompetent from
day one.
It it'll go away on its own.
This is no big deal.
We have no cases.
The United States, even with the little amount
of testing that we are doing, are rapidly
in get heading in the direction of being one
of the countries with the most cases in the
world.
Now, of course, we have a really large population.
But remember, we had quote, leaders telling
us we would likely see very few cases here.
Dr. Anthony Foushee, who's the director of
the National Institute of Allergy and Infectious
Disease, he now is saying straight up, cancel
or postpone any event with 50 or 50 or more
people for eight weeks, eight weeks, too,
as a starting point.
That's a long time.
I get it.
But understand that the way these infection
curves go every day that it grows is another
day on the tail end you need for the decline.
Without a vaccine or treatments, if you have
10 days of case growth before you turn it
around, you need 10 days of declines to get
back to where we are today.
If you delay slowing down case growth for
15 days, you then need 15 days on the back
end before you get back to where we are today.
Meaning for every day we don't deal with this.
We are actually losing 2 days minimum.
Not to mention the exponentially disastrous
effect on the medical system as ICU become
overwhelmed as we lack ventilators.
So this will add up quickly.
Today's day 14 in the United States of that
steady case growth.
Imagine where we will be in another 14 days
if we don't turn it around.
So in that context, states are starting to
shut down.
The federal government is not doing what they
need to do here.
They have been far too slow.
They have been far too dishonest.
They're just making things up whole cloth,
which I will talk to you about momentarily.
So Ohio is shutting down bars and restaurants,
period.
Now, remember, some places may be ignoring
the decrees at their peril.
And it's true that there are places which
will say shut down and people won't do it.
And local police are not going to be able
to necessarily enforce every single bar or
restaurant following the rules.
It requires people doing it.
It requires restaurants doing it.
Illinois has ordered bars and restaurants
to close starting tonight until March 30th.
That's a couple of weeks almost here in Massachusetts,
Governor Charlie Baker says.
All gatherings of more than 25 people are
banned.
Restaurants can be takeout only until April
6th at minimum, and possibly all the way until
April 17th.
Some conflicting reports about the exact dates.
Schools are closed.
Things are closing down.
California Gov. Gavin Newsom says California
will be closing bars, nightclubs and wineries
and that everyone aged 65 and over should
be self isolating.
Do not go out in public.
Washington State is shutting down restaurants,
bars, entertainment and recreational facilities.
Restaurants will be allowed to do takeout
and delivery.
There are people who still say, you know,
there aren't that many cases.
We have three hundred and forty million people
and we have thirty five hundred cases as of
right now.
No one understand that.
We don't have thirty five hundred cases.
By some estimates we likely have between one
and five hundred thousand cases.
We are just not testing.
We're not testing.
We don't know how many cases we have.
There are people who will say this is simply
going too far when you understand the math
of viral contagion.
You realize you have to do it before it's
too late because otherwise it's too late.
It needs to feel like it's too early because
otherwise you're going to be behind the curve.
And look at what happened in Italy.
It's a tragedy what's happening in Italy.
They did too much, too slowly.
And now they have more active cases than China,
despite having a population that's 96 percent
smaller than China's.
Think about that.
And that's because of delays.
Every day matters.
You've got to turn the corner on the new case.
No meaning.
You need to change the inflection of the curve
from more new cases each day to fewer new
cases each day.
When you look at new cases in the United States.
It's up every day.
This is the time to shut it down, because
otherwise, in 10 days, the U.S. could look
like Italy.
If this comes to your state and it likely
will at the rate that we're going be part
of the solution, don't be part of the problem.
And by the way, don't hoard, OK?
The hoarding situation is getting very bad.
There was no toilet paper shortage expected.
Rumors swirled that there would be a shortage.
Think about why.
Why would all of a sudden there be assured
it just doesn't actually make sense.
People buying all the toilet paper they see
creates an artificial shortage.
And you have tragic stories of elderly couples
driving around all over the place not feeling
well.
In many cases, looking for a roll of toilet
paper because you have people and I'll play
videos momentarily.
People fighting.
It's like Black Friday looking for the cheap
TV over toilet paper.
I went to my local a couple local grocery
stores.
[00:06:53][386.2]
[00:06:54] All all yogurt was gone.
All eggs were gone.
All meat was gone.
Frozen vegetables, frozen food all gone.
[00:07:02][8.4]
[00:07:03] Fresh produce, by the way.
Plenty of people, I guess, completely ignoring
that at this point.
Don't hoard get, you know, build up a strategic
supply of a couple of weeks of food, which
most of us should have anyway, to a couple
of weeks is reasonable and non-perishables
and understand that you will make the problem
worse.
It's really, really bad.
What's going on?
[00:07:23][19.7]
[418.1]